you follow politics you're very
political I do like politics I don't
know I don't know if you guys have heard
about Donald Trump yeah I have I don't
know yeah yeah the apprentice yes I
decided I'm going to throw all my
support to him you're gonna support I'm
gonna formally I would like to take this
opportunity to endorse Donald Trump okay
resident I mean politically I don't
agree with him on anything yeah I like
Hillary Clinton all right yeah but you
just gotta admire what I wanted what a
dick he is like he has like the same
like way of speaking of like like a
waiter at like an Italian chain
restaurant Italian chain restaurant yeah
like if you're like yeah how's that
what's mr. Getty don't worry about it's
fantastic you're gonna love it it's the
best spaghetti you've ever had if you're
like Buca di Beppo yeah that's great you
want that right and you're on you're
paying like you know $6.99 for some pie
hey come on it's fun but you can't have
him like negotiating you know don't
worry Putin invades of Ukraine he's
gonna hate what happens to him trust me
I want to hear your plan give us one
specific of anything but I am formally
supporting him you're gonna support him
all right
do you think you're gonna people gonna
get tired of this Trump phenomena we'll
never get tired of Trump it's it's like
it's it's like in there will be blood
that great movie Daniel day-lewis like
there's oil for a thousand years it's
like we have the O and the only other
person who's like doing well is like Ben
Carson and that guy cannot be President
because he's got the least presidential
voice he sounds like like a like a
stoned librarian he's like yeah he's
like oh that is that would be upstairs
you can take the elevator but I think
it's out of order
and like you can't we can't have a voice
like that you need a song yeah you're
gonna Andy Richter voice yeah and yes
you do need an Andy Rhynie and irritate
us